(gasping)
- What?
- What's up guys.
My name's Chris and I'm a video producer,
out here in New York.
Today, I'm going to find my co-workers
some pizza for lunch.
But we're not talking about regular pizza.
We're not talking about
your boring toppings,
like pepperoni and mushroom
and all that lame shit.
We're actually looking for a pizza,
that has smaller pizzas on top of it.
Pizza topped with pizza,
which is insane.
"Chris, where in the sweet hell
are you going to find
something like that?"
We're heading to Vinnie's
Pizzeria in Brooklyn.
Ladies and gentlement...
We found it.
It is in the oven right now,
and I can't wait to see this.
Alright guys, we've got
the goods right there.
Let's head back to the office.
- Pizza is amazing.
- Pizza is so fucking good.
- It's just like my go-to.
- I feel like I get a lotta shit,
because I like mushrooms on my pizza.
See, case in point.
- That's disgusting.
- I do like toppings, when
someone else is paying.
- I feel like it's going to be
something that is a weird topping.
- I'm so nervous.
I don't know what this is gonna be.
- I'm pretty sure you're
going to give us a pizza,
with like a shoe,
and like a pickle.
- Aww.
(laughing)
- Wow.
(Italian music playing)
- Oh snap.
It's pizza and its little babies.
- It's little baby pizzas.
Oh my gosh.
- This is adorable.
- I feel like this is going to taste
like all my childhood dreams come true.
- Do you eat the...
Just all together?
- You eat it together.
- Oh my god.
- Oh this is actually really good pizza.
- It just has more of it on top.
Can you...
Can I like peel it off.
- Yeah I wanna peel it off.
- You just have to use
like your whole hand.
Like this.
- I would never fold this,
because it's just so beautiful.
I don't wanna, like, smush them together.
- (whispers) I'm folding it.
- I'm sorry to eat your sister.
- I'm going to eat this
whole goddam thing.
This is so good.
- Oh, I'm savoring it.
- Whoever came up with this,
I like your mind.
- If I saw it on the street,
I would pick it up and eat it.
- One and one thirds pizza,
so it's 33% better than regular pizza.
Math, it's math.
(laughing)
It's pizza math.
- Is there more, that we can eat?
Or is this it?
- [Chris] This is it.
- Oh.
- He hasn't even finished
this one, and wants another.
You really like pizza...